risque ferroviaire comportement citoyen
à bord des trains ou encore importance
d'acheter et de composter son billet ce
sont quelques-uns des thèmes développés
ce matin au lycée henri matisse attrape
les élèves de la troisième classe prépa
pro ont rencontré un agent
d'intervention en milieu scolaire de
sncf
chaque année 30 agents conducteurs de
trains agents de terrain aux agents
commerciaux échange avec 25000 jeunes
franciliens
les précisions au micro de mélanie poté
pour la sncf c'est ce qu'on appelle les
coûts évités
lorsqu'on rencontre des jeunes demain on
sait que ces jeunes là vous en prêter
nos lignes et donc ils vont être au fait
du danger quand ils vont emprunter un
ligne demain aujourd'hui même le jeu que
j'ai rencontré tout de suite la neuve a
pu tirer le signal d'alarmé
eelv a pu bloquer les portes parce qu'il
sait que ses portes la bloquer ça
retarde du train je crois que ça fait
partie aussi de l'éducation la
citoyenneté que quand même notre
ministre nous demande grandement de
mettre en place dans les établissements
scolaires le vivre ensemble la laïcité